my appeal today is for anyone who knows
where either of these two cars were kept
prior to the shooting or has knowledge
of their movements on the day of the
shooting to come forward
we need this information
I'm also appealing for anyone who
observed anything suspicious in the
recoupler road area of oma on the night
of the shooting and an odd bow the
following night Thursday the 23rd of
February
did you see anyone or any vehicles in
these areas Did You observe any Vehicles
driving away at speed
we really need you to come forward with
this information to help the
investigation and bring those
responsible for this attack on John to
Justice
I'm going to hand over now to Mick Duffy
Crime Stoppers director of operations
who will provide an update on the reward
being offered for information leading to
the arrest and conviction of the people
involved in attempting to murder Jon
good morning firstly I on behalf of
everybody at Crime Stoppers wish to
express our great sadness and shock at
this awful attack on DCI Caldwell and
our thoughts are with him and his family
at this time
I'm the director of operations at the
independent charity Crime Stoppers and
like John I'm also the father of a young
family and a kids football coach
so this despicable attack really
resonates with me as I'm sure it does
with many others here in Northern
Ireland and Beyond
I want to start by explaining what our
charity is what we do to keep people
safe and then announce on a significant
increase to the reward we're offering
firstly and importantly I want people to
know that we are not the police
we obviously work closely with them
and we pass on a significant amount of
anonymous information from the public
every day
but I want to assure you we are totally
independent from them
the police know that we cannot pass on
personal information about those who
contact us because we simply do not have
that ourselves
this means that when somebody contacts
the charity there are no courts no
police
no witness statements and no comeback
tell us what you know and then you're
done
I now want to turn to our reward
we know the original 20 000 pounds for
information leading to John's attackers
has encouraged people to come forward
and this is positive and we are told
it's making a difference
like everyone across Northern Ireland
Beyond we want those responsible for the
shooting to be brought to Justice
today
with this I want to announce sorry today
I want to announce that with through the
generosity of anonymous donors in
Northern Ireland we are now increasing
our reward for information
leading to the arrest and conviction up
to a total of a hundred and fifty
thousand pounds
this is one of the highest rewards the
charity has ever offered
and this money is available to you
if it leads to the conviction of the
shooting
if you have information but prefer not
to speak to the police contact us by
visiting our website
search online at Crimestoppers UK
or by calling our 24 7 contact center on
the free phone number 0800 treble five
treble one
you can only claim the reward if you
come to Crime Stoppers
like our phone and online reporting
service our rewards process is also
Anonymous you just need to ask for a
reward code
if you know who was involved and have
information come to us and keep safe
thank you for your time today
we're keeping an open mind as to the
exact role of the second car
but we do believe that due to the
information we have around the purchase
the movements and the fact that both
cars were burnt out shortly after the
attack on John that they were both
involved in the attack in some way
s
this attack was carried out by the new
Ira that is the main line of inquiry I'm
aware of speculation around the
background of those involved
the background of the people involved is
either terrorists
nature organized crime nature or both
but this attack was carried out by the
new IRA and that is our main line of
inquiry
these people are quite clearly very
dangerous and we need information to put
them behind bars where they should be so
I'm pleased today that working with
Crime Stoppers we are in a position
to offer a reward of 150 000 pounds that
is a significant award it's a
significant amount of money so please
anyone Supply what information you know
to Crime Stoppers and leave their ass to
us
yes
yes the blue Ford Fiesta the first
vehicle burned the registration Mark frz
8414 traveled into coal Island at around
10 pm on the evening of the 21st
uh be arrested and that's the case are
you disappointed you haven't got any
order for the courtship
our main aim is to bring people in front
of the courts but we deal with the
evidence we have and we follow the
evidence so whilst I'm disappointed that
we haven't brought people before the
courts at this stage
these investigations are particularly
challenging and they take time
the investigation is at a very early
stage
and we will use any information that is
supplied to us the reward is significant
and we need people to come forward that
one little piece of information May
close a gap that we have
we're working closely with our
colleagues in the AGS and that's all I'm
prepared to say around that at this
moment in time
officers
is completely vile second in and
disgusting
we're taking the amp threat seriously
and all staff are regularly reminded and
have been reminded about their own
personal security on and off duty